was ist da bloß in den kanzlerkandidaten
der union gefahren bundespräsident frank
walter steinmeier kontrolliert im
katastrophengebiet wo zahlreiche
menschen tot geborgen wurden wo
unzählige noch vermisst werden wo dörfer
weggerissen und die infrastruktur
niedergewalzt worden ist steinmeier
appelliert und bewundert den gemeinsinn
trifft den richtigen ton und hinter ihm
albert armin laschet nrw-regierungschef
und kanzlerkandidat als sei er im
karneval und nicht in der todeszone der
flut das gibt es eigentlich gar nicht
also mitten im leid lacht armin laschet
ist eigentlich völlig egal warum und
worüber es ist eine unsägliche situation
benimmt sich nach allen regeln des
anstands vollkommen daneben
frank walter steinmeier spricht zur
nation der pressekonferenz mit dem
bundespräsidenten ist ja eine ansprache
die eine tonlage hat dem ereignis dem
schrecklichen ereignis das wir jetzt
alle miterleben rechnung trägt und und
sozusagen stimme verleiht und dann steht
im hintergrund eine gruppe von
flegelhaften jungs die da irgendwie über
irgendwas vorziehen der eine ist der
landrat der andere ist armin laschet der
kanzlerkandidat und was erschwerend
hinzu kommt der ministerpräsident von
nordrhein-westfalen es geht also um das
leid im land doch es gibt auch eben und
das leid in seinem land er ist auch der
mann der auch bei dieser pressekonferenz
geredet hat und sein ganzes mitgefühl
ausdruck verliehen hat einst kann ja
nicht stimmen
entweder das mitgefühl oder das lachen
es passt jedenfalls nicht zusammen wenn
jemand mit fühlt ehrlich mit fühlt wenn
jemand wirklich berührt ist wenn jemand
die situation mitnimmt und das ist schon
das was armin laschet auch vorgegeben
hat dann kann man nicht wenige minuten
später in einer solch
ausgelassenen stimmung sein